or maybe no one's watching as a state
you can just sell Joe exactly because
he's in prison yeah I see a ton of
people making time to change shirts and
[ __ ] yeah
and by that we mean Tom Segura
[Laughter]
back off my broccolini
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching
[Music]
[Laughter]
wake up one earPod oh yeah yeah both
them in from what
yes called - dude it's crazy I'm Brendan
doesn't know that many numbers I'm a
dumb one we got lunch lady gloves on
freaking disease upcoming tasks I'm at
each one and y'all gonna die but I don't
think so your funeral taking your wallet
and you head into the ground uh gonna
stop anything don't ever touch me bro oh
then it's a good idea to stop biting my
nails yeah
wrinkly shirt used to be a shirt now
this is a mask so creative
yeah man you guys don't know [ __ ] man
what do you guys been doing living
living not getting Corona you look like
you're trying to keep Corona end dude
what am I
you look like Larry Corona do you okay
the guy that started it somewhere
outside of New Jersey like Boy George's
Mina side piece it's a gloves sloppy joe
gloves I've ever seen and you look like
you just saw penguins on the dark web
[Laughter]
that's his profile nice you look like
freakin Larry Corona stalking shady dude
you look like you'd be on real thought
husbands of Quran
County dude you don't like the worst
scarecrow right now there's only trying
to scare girls away oh yeah but
welcoming the gay guys no guys I allow
them I get that painted on this side of
it you been up to dude I'm chillin alive
man taking care of myself
huh take it I'll drill it I'm in here
yeah you're good thank you good you good
we're like a scarf well I don't want to
is cover up mine too cool Jersey that I
have yeah shut up the Houston cheating
actresses the fans didn't know doll get
to our rep son yeah I run the city
so yeah the worst thing is it's hard to
use your phone with these Corona mitts
on those are Corona myths those are
protective keeps thinking they do the
job you want to extra scoop of breakfast
I got it you want an extra scoop of iris
don't have it so it's how safe I am dude
you get tested
no uh-uh a friend of mine got tested
though and they're fine so you good I'm
not good but it definitely takes the
edge off a little bit you know yeah if a
close buddy got tested you know not a
buddy who had it I love up Vernon's like
hey man what do you cuz you're [ __ ]
Patrick Swayze wig was blocking the
other one figured it's like hey why do
you have two ones what do you have what
do you have what do you got that yeah
well your mom right now is like what do
you have one of your pot and then one
ear pod in I'm like to Britain okay it's
the big adventure after the number one
you tell a joke and I hear extreme it's
later
telephone you'll assume oh yeah they're
disgusting man not you guys but some of
y'all kid stays on it chin ain't gonna
get ya ya know it's for me not to pass
it on to anyone else you don't but you
don't have it but just in case you never
know I never got a test just being safe
for everyone else Nick what is that uh
what jerseys that genre Donald Driver
all-time leader in receptions down
drivers yeah the guy that [ __ ] killed
Donte Stallworth crossing that
interstate in Miami was that who that is
no well there's a different Donald it
was a driver yeah damn down driver won
Dancing with the Stars that's right oh
the football players do well did Jerry
Rice want it too I think he did you saw
I saw your tweet you got a 90 day fiancé
oh yeah I get to the guy with no neck oh
yeah the little uh I think you see
Philippine or big it his spine isn't
sprouted that's what happened if you
look at it yes head just yeah just
everything hasn't sprouted you know he's
like it that little spud yeah I bet if
you tickle a Martin off dude where I
grew up that a lot people would tickle
you really [ __ ] hard dogs make you
grow a couple inch Oh bra make you
[ __ ] make your head wanna pop off
your body what's his name huh again is
that big in that's that little guy yeah
yeah it was good man I'm at the part
right now where dude there's so much
going only great oh yeah the white girl
with the rapper told your boy oh yeah
soldier boy yeah and he says a music
video he's not that bad no he's not that
well he's the best guy in South Africa
yeah and then or the Congo I think
Nigeria yeah that's right yeah so I'm
saying it was a short I
have you got the anywhere he has the
music video haha any of the he has a sob
in it on his girl gets pissed I'm gonna
watch this right now it's called before
the 90 day fiancé
yeah so I haven't seen any of it until
now and it's just alarming man it makes
you gives you hope huh I don't know they
can do it you can do it
yeah that's your head with no neck found
the girl in the Philippines
Theo can do it dude yeah there he is
right there god he's handsome dude hell
yeah hey how about so she doesn't shave
her legs and they have sex for the first
time and he's like listen you gotta
shave your legs when I keep doing this
and she gets all pissed she's like I'll
do it if you shave your beard she has
that boy shave his beard huh just when
you didn't think I could get any uglier
really this boy he's handsome dude where
I'm from he's handsome he's at least a
freakin sick that makes sense
he's a he's a solid one from there he's
straight thanks bro Luke please you can
say some fake diamond on a scale of one
to ten we should get him on this past
weekend if Nick would [ __ ] do his job
makes you busy finding decent players
from [ __ ] the stage I got a Clay
Matthews Jersey it's starting to get
white that's where you know it's getting
bad Aaron Rodgers I know you got it
Aaron Rodgers you got a you got a Reggie
White those are all the Emperor jerseys
I got a Melvin Gordon Wisconsin native
t-shirt t-shirt Jersey don't worry we
but yeah they have a lot of money you
should get that Mitchell and no longer
edition they got Reggie White who else
who else wears the r.i.p jerseys man
they got that you can get a Jerome Brown
from that Mitchell and Asness really
that Nestle that Mitchell Nestle's room
Brown died member yeah he did die so did
Reggie white boy thank to well support
for King in the sting you know what it
comes from official electric razor of
UFC Wow yep manscaped have you ever had
an awkward
we had to spar against someone Brendan
who had a full Bush coming out of their
singlet too many times bro oh yeah too
many times nothing worse than a bush in
your face when getting taken down woohoo
well manscape is the best in men's
below-the-belt grooming and their
top-notch ball trimmer called the lawn
mower 3.0 will keep you clean hmm now
Nixon cuts that's right why Nick and cut
you junk
tighten up dude sometimes when I'm
cutting my junk and I nicked them nuts
and they don't stop bleeding oh they'll
bleed out oh I'll save the blood dude
I'll save the blood and use it on plants
or something I'll donate it yeah don't
it so much I'm bleeding on my nutsack
not anymore though thanks to manscape
the lawn mower 3.0 comes inside their
new perfect package 3.0 which makes you
step up your grooming game it's
literally everything you need to keep
that thing trimmed and looking fresh and
real friendly yep that's right
MMA fanatics listen up don't use the
same trimmer on your face as you're
using on your balls that's nasty hey the
lawn mower 3.0 comes inside their new
perfect package 3.0 dude what about the
crop preserver you know I'm talking
about that little deodorant for your
nutsack yeah you want you to nuts to be
tight you want your nursing your Nertz
to be Church ready bro yeah man get 20%
off and free shipping with the code king
sting at manscape com give the perfect
gift for your nuts and your sparring
partner that's right get 20% off sand
free shipping with the code King sting
at manscape calm that's 20% offs with
free shipping zat may escape calm and
use code King sting thank you for
supporting mixed martial arts worldwide
uh dude did you know 40 percent of men
by age 40 struggle from not being able
to get that frickin erection Rocking
what up said dude dude I knew that by
age 24 I just found out at age 37 oh
really
sometimes my dicks like nah not today
it's like on the reinforcements I said
there's anything out there and then for
hims calm a one-stop shop for hair loss
skin care and you dick came out of the
Woodworks and said guess what man we'll
link you up with real licensed doctors
and fda-approved pharmaceutical products
to treat your dick Amen praise God
brother what I'm telling you this is
that your
as part of your body man and sometimes
your body you go to the gym and your
body's like yeah some time you reach for
something your arm doesn't work you know
you try to kick your buddy or [ __ ] or
eat up pick a berry with your toes
sometimes when your eyes won't open up
it's tired
it's tired man and that's life but for
hims it wants to do the background work
for you so when you go to use part of
your body like your Weiner you can yes
all you gotta do is answer a few quick
questions and then guess what a real
medical professional looks it over and
send you what you need nothing
try hims today by starting out with a
free online visit go to four hems fo are
hims calm slash cats k ATS five that's
four hems calm / K 80s and the number
five four hems calm / Katz 5c website
for full details and safety information
yeah this could cost hundreds if you
went to a doctor in person we don't need
that man remember that's for hems calm /
k 80s 5 let's go back to big yet yeah
hey bring up bring up the white girl
who's made in the black marrying the
black guy the black guys definitely
managed all of that green I mean Lisa oh
yeah yeah good job dude I thought about
it a little thought I would do nine-day
fiance I could decide in nine days I
feel like me what the hell's he doing
with her eight ninety day now with her
it hurts wrong with man that nice
good-looking gentleman he gonna roll
with that what do you got call through
some [ __ ] to get to America bro you
gotta also decide your sexuality before
you start judging the picture dude
obviously the lady is way a dime
compared to him because he's a man okay
so if a you if you're interested in
women then you're gonna be more
interested for her then you are the guy
right Melissa's drug-induced
you're a mouse rolling around dude it is
gonna be nice
Mattox bright all in it no Fiona we
can't overlook that he said Method Man 1
plus 1 equals [ __ ] uh Soulja Boy oh
and then there's that one older dude
who's going after the Russian and she's
gone am i I am ia like seven times on
him and he keeps going to Russia
searching for it oh yeah that's right
right now and he's just going over there
gosh she never shows up she [ __ ] dude
give it up what it's 90 day fiancé
yeah it was gonna be chaos now it's not
what do you think should do show up on
the 8th time well I'm like I think you
give somebody four or five chances
change rate on campus you give somebody
some international chances Brendan
you're an idiot that's fair well if you
traveled if you have if you hadn't
canceled all your European dates like
you did why have you because of corona
yeah if you were [ __ ] not a legend
you have to says the guy who canceled
shows in brain could be on a cold sovery
you wanna do this I've never missed the
show yeah I've been there do a full
weekend the worst driver I've ever it
sitting out there I'm not even joking
you're starting to feel had a sore knee
and cancel this sold-out shows in brain
yeah bro happy dude dummy for 17 years
O'Reilly sold out Brant had a kink in
his neck and cancelled the shuttles is
for brain doesn't have an aneurysm cuz
how do I want to apologize organizing
the brain I would t like to apologize to
you guys but I would like to say this
that Brendan if you'll pull him up Nick
if you didn't just quit your job if you
pull up Brendan he looks like long ed if
you have big a head and long hair and
you put them right next to each other
did you know whose y'all harder to do
that you know anybody already do that
you know he should get with is the girls
from thousand-pound sisters really
that's it
have you seen that show Oh living
thousand-pound sisters dude let's go to
our urban connoisseur right here chubby
chicks uh no really can't say that cuz
the one she's she's so thick
she's will she's a thickest person
you've ever seen she has fat on her
forehead oh wow yeah it's like growing
out of here what I think roll baby dick
you're not you're not into fat chicks
either no one's into chubby cheese
because I think roll PJ right up above
her eyebrows I can't say I've never been
[Laughter]
if you don't think Nick is been into a
thick look at the kind of guy will take
a gun and put a little and just shoot it
on the ground near a woman yeah see she
bites burning I'm telling you look I'm
long-eared bro I'm telling you bro if
you tickled it little bit or big add
hard enough dude it would be you but a
hairstyles bro yeah you think about this
dude I will say this about big ant-man
he's extremely charming oh well I do
notice this though it seemed like he's
very chatty chatty and sweats a lot
oh the dangerous combo do you tell the
chicks not into him and we got have you
got there he gave no I haven't gotten
far
I don't know where you're at dude huh
the show's been going on for months
that's it
yeah I just got a new it last night I
was I got in I saw Michael Rapaport up
at 2:00 a.m. screaming about Donald
Trump on Twitter hey switch it up switch
it up it is correct by commercial
dropping rapid him yell yeah also rap
get off the truck dude switch up your
material for God dude I'll tell you this
micro rapid work just because I
I'm gonna vote for Donald Trump now
because he goes led me to it yeah this
is you're doing wrong it has nothing to
do with him dude it's all because of you
bro because of you I don't know ya know
I bring up them to SiC whales on
thousand-pound sister for me wait have
you been with a big dude no well she was
with home beliefs since like eighth
grade you guys can handle it yeah yeah
she was obviously they arranged it was
you're right she's purring oh yeah
arranged in high school huh look at that
funny two minutes are they you know
thing about having them open up from me
and Brea oh well dude I bet if it gets
late enough and you've had enough liquor
you'll have them open up for you oh like
you and me plus 400 pounds ones real
mean and what real cool my hair that
lady so they waited on regular scales
you have to go to a junkyard to use the
scales no we're so happy
that's a loo minim yard Oh mommy though
they're fun they have a YouTube channel
that's how they got the TLC found them
I have a funny youtube channel but the
big one has it has a gets a boyfriend
this black dude he comes over and she's
like really and then we find out married
black dude they're married he was
married oh he was dude dude that's a
side we don't do it yeah don't do with a
sigh peace on any other side peace bro
that is a side that's a side dish there
he is oh hey this froze oh man
[Applause]
you think you could beat her in a fight
or not I'd be tough man
where would you attack her what would
your will you would it be more straight
to that body Sonny what yeah straight
that that liver can't be doing well
thank you straight to the body
yeah me and what uh how many rounds
would you got huh what do you think you
take her in the first round
no it's gonna be a drawn-out she's gonna
at least 24 minutes you got from
Wolverine
yeah x-men car - you could punch that
guy cuz your fists would just go right
in his belly that's orbit exactly what
you're talking about that's right
I wonder if when you get so much weight
away from your actual like-like-like
organs and bones can you feel it as much
you know what I'm saying absorbs a
little more you know because like if you
gave if one of us gets hit like we're
gonna feel it like in our bones and [ __ ]
yeah but if you get hit and it's just a
bunch of weight I wonder what that feels
because there's a whole layer of fat
yeah it's almost awesome yeah almost
like a super flower but without the
sister you know their whole goal is to
get that bypass stomach surgery no and
the one skinnier sister got it and then
this big the the thick thick one didn't
qualify Oh because you couldn't stop
eating really well they toss bacon
lasagna oh yeah bacon lasagna these
homes do it everything was on she goes
you know it'd be really good she's like
why she was if we had a bacon
if big is your thing you got a cell you
gotta just I feel like you go as big as
you can't look at Liz oh she owns it
don't ya this does she owns it
yeah her ass was out at a Lakers game or
something like correct what do you guys
think
uh Kat and Chappelle or what anything
jebel what's the biggest you've ever
been I've been around cheerleaders so
well I'm saying what's the biggest
you've ever been though like biggest
I've ever been fat before uh no I don't
think I've ever been fat I just I mean
I've always been thick but I've never
been like fat you know Jim was almost
300 pounds almost leaner pounds weight
why five mm-hmm really order two are you
serious yeah picture there's Piggy's
problem on picture it looks like you oh
it's the same Hawkins dance it looks
like I'm a ventriloquist I'm not even
kidding
are you Seri I'm serious bring that [ __ ]
up we're gonna need to see this a set
yeah Jim's tree is very my old pictures
that crazy I worked long and hard yeah
you been fat I never been fat man I'll
wait when I was a child I was like in
the seven hundred percentile for weight
though I was born and I was like yeah I
was like 13 pound baby oh [ __ ] you want
to be sick as a baby I'm one like
biggest baby in like our county or
whatever for first so when I was born
damn I won the biggest baby in our
county wait for when I was born thanks
dude they already it's my baby book and
everything but that's cool and how
scared of that little girl first of all
that girl looks edible and second of all
how is your name the only thing you
can't even find
what are you were the best like that
those are young dude bro he's a Maitre
D' obviously but when you are if you are
a hundred percent Asian which I'm
assuming Jin is you have to Maitre D' is
like one of the it's like a popular
attire what's up with your pants those
are Jenko zinc oh I can tell what it was
yeah she looks scared
du brim [ __ ] looks like a guy who
fixes video games machine but claims he
has another job - how great is that
picture Jin Jin how do you lose the
weight I tried everything even high
school I tried slim fast
you never slim fast yeah it was so
embarrassing so I do you know get like
foil to cover it because I didn't want
people to see I was really little bags
that tried everything if I finally like
after just not eating that much seemed
to work yeah you try just fast and don't
use many carbs that's the goal right
just don't eat as much while dude and
how did you lose the how do you lose now
Friar Tuck wedding attire he went out of
style after a while yeah dude a style
after Robin Hood Texas now this is here
in orange bro you look like deep Friar
Tuck that an Asian dad is trying to
[ __ ] get into a wedding look it's so
true I did look like a girl like a
beautiful lady no thank you you
shouldn't think down about yourself
beautiful lady but definitely you got
that straight up F talk vide son
that fart easy dog you ever think about
sumo like to actually do it ya know
you're gonna win that way you know what
if you even Brendan win it up into
fighting each other in some
international sumo still going on still
poppin they still do it all wanna know
if it's still going on right now
well I doubt it so it's still poppin
who's the Yokozuna right now look it up
brother
marry Yokozuna and owf yes Yokozuna
really he's a giant Asian dude big dude
who's the current Yokozuna only two
active Yokozuna now remain in
professional sumo wrestling kissing nuts
all they do is eat white rice and map
cream and their legends were when they
died a young age meant yeah wow that's a
big this would be it's a big heart
yeah so who's gonna die man we got a
figure uh we haven't done this for a
while some race my case oh let's do it
so in this one a a mother was walking
with her ten month old baby in a mall to
meet her husband and son in arcade and a
woman ran up from behind and punched her
ten month old baby for no reason she
took off there was swelling bruising
around the eye and after posting the
security footage on social media they
apprehended the suspect that's a crazy
white girl probably on meth yeah it
sounds like a schizo Freni a thing so
I'm gonna take it out of a I don't see a
lot of Asians get to phrenic so I'm
gonna take it out of the Asian realm I'm
gonna I'm kind of in black or white what
are the races are there no accent could
be angry what if the baby was of a
different she cheated and the baby was
with a different man and he punched the
baby like a novela [ __ ] the baby dog you
don't say baby ten years ago
yeah I agree I'll say that dude you know
who I represent today Houston bro we do
what everyone takes to [ __ ] wins baby
had to take those medals from you with
do that baby could be stealing signals
they don't make me scoop some [ __ ]
yams into your [ __ ] coffee I'm going
white I'm going white girl on drugs
thought the baby was the demon punch in
the face same white i'm knighting I
imagine Asian for some reason people
they do hit young people yep that's oh
yeah
good for them eh is that true though
Asian parents will hit their kids I'm
sure I've been hit I used to get my ass
beat yeah wow really yeah I think all
ethnicities hit their kids what's
hitting other kids is the question other
people's kids they'll spank your other
kids like 15 years ago it got really
weird like spank your kid when Adrian
Peterson spanked his kid and everybody
got mad well used a switch yeah I would
rather that he hit me with a switch then
he hit me with Adrian Peterson's hand
[Laughter]
his son has to try to use a small piece
of a tree dude yeah that would do that
[ __ ] champ remember that's why you
had to leave Minnesota yeah locked him
[ __ ] that kid up though he didn't [ __ ]
that kid up dude that kid had a couple
of licks on his legs I'm not saying that
I feel like you're anti kid today which
is kind of weird but it's rose the
gloves the lunch lady glows I don't know
what it is dude
maybe you're right man maybe it's 90 day
fiancé just ruining my hope and
relationships that should give you hope
dude if those scumbags can figure out
what about the dad from Tennessee that's
always acting like he's a mime I feel
like I feel like he always is like
making things with his eyes like he's
stuck in a box but doesn't really tell
anybody all right what are we talking
about
I thought Adrian Peterson dude I say
white the woman who punched the baby was
Asian
oh listen to it yes
I did man do we watch it yeah
the victim was 10 month old Alexia s-sir
although Alexia was all smiles today
remnants of yet baby
for no reason I've never seen a woman
before we hadn't talked to anyone we
have no idea why she would hit our
daughter was she getting the girl or the
daughter
look she's swimming for the mom yeah now
did she think the little girl was a bat
what's going on here looks like Boris
Johnson from the England I think you
failed to go for him because you [ __ ]
some issue us for sure time I chronic
hey mother time you canceled on Brad to
hit a sore foot well that bro there when
you have sold-out shows and three days
before her because you had a runny nose
you canceled on Brown I was having an
exorcism
you okay I want to take my own life
what's next you can punch a baby that
maybe looks just like a young boy or or
or the lady from thousand-pound sisters
yes she's the last pound the last pound
okay number two
so Chin's in the lead bullshitting using
his own race that's insider trading
that's used to know yeah you get to wear
the jersey now a woman was found guilty
of firing into a McDonald's restaurant
at 28th Street and Madison in February
because she was upset that the
restaurant apparently left the bacon off
her cheeseburger for the second time
that is frustrating
[Laughter]
that's black but where does he have that
piece from no I don't feel like you see
a lot of black women with guns you know
I feel like you see a lot of black men
with guns you see a lot of black women
with gun really and it was a woman at
sad net yeah guns like women mmm black
okay stick in the black I'll go black
man I mean I definitely convinced you
huh twenty-eight then Madison it sounds
like an area where there might be some
black people oh yeah she's got a gun
okay hold on it was black horn with
extremely short hair if you say
extremely short hair or black moon with
semi fade I would have been like yeah
possible pistol the Amber Rose right
that's a bummer all right last one I can
imagine it gets heated at some of those
joints yeah I mean sometimes my post may
flower sushi they forget my eel sauce
well that sucks when they forget
something if you make fake eel sauce it
makes the meal yeah you [ __ ] me
you just make fake eel sauce at home
it's gonna find the meal yeah you gotta
get a goldfish out of the tank and
convince that bastard to give up his
sauce you got a hold a small plastic gun
to his head like kissing his cub boy
[Laughter]
35-year old man faces multiple charges
he blamed on driving while having
intercourse the arrest stemmed from an
off-duty deputy witnessing a four-runner
fishtailing all over the road
tearing up a county highway the deputy
could smell a strong odor of alcoholic
beverage and once they stopped the man
he said he was having sex with his
girlfriend yeah okay also just pull over
though you know uh he's like yeah for
runner-runner fishtailing listen to that
kind of music
white drunk yeah highway oh I can see
the girl that was up to have sex in the
4runner yeah I'm a high-end he looks
like Boris Johnson a little think this
is the first day we kind of got all them
rights up that first one yeah it was
better than most better than most should
move on some qinger sting it is a
beautiful young lady or man I don't know
what you call people today Sophia what's
up Brandon what's up cat Nick Chincha
pal I hope you're not forgetting anybody
but uh I can't understand that candor
stinging his shotgunning I've already
done it [ __ ] three times I'm [ __ ]
stupid can't say the word I was gonna
say but um because you can already see
I've done it Oh several times and I keep
[ __ ] up but in my opinion there's
only one thing to do to beat Corona and
that's to change it up [ __ ] these
sunglasses um yeah I want to get your
guy's opinion on shotgunning I [ __ ] up
because I haven't been using a beer like
a [ __ ] because it's just a shotgun with
a beer as everybody knows so here we go
[Music]
grungy Green sweats he's in shape huh
but I'll say this dude uh this guy looks
like [ __ ] that looks like Elvis's son
a little bit
with the shades on like LC no I didn't
see that coming to you I'm telling you
man this guy's gotta he could be the
next Elvis man Ivan I don't I can't
realized I'm a shotgun to bear
do you see uh [ __ ] what's the name the
starting quarterback for Rogers no Baker
Mayfield do you see him when he's at the
game
I think it's Cleveland Indians a shotgun
the [ __ ] out of that beer got the crowd
crunk - [ __ ] before game yeah is it
finally tonight Baker Mayfield and a
Cleveland Indians game it's like
shopping creases no I'm not gonna chug
it I'm gonna shotgun it eyes on the big
screen shotgunning the beer and just
living his best life everyone you made
all those commercials then he bomb that
season four uh and then they do
commercials they thought he was gonna be
the man he's underdog I thought they'd
do well they've surrounded him with
everything but they started with a lot
of ego up there - Oh BJ seems like a
[ __ ] nightmare there's no chemistry
on that team the coach with kitchens
with a [ __ ] [ __ ] was he's gone they
should be better this year the drafts
Thursday night being out biggest not
your life and you got a face time from
the [ __ ] Denver Broncos we select you
with a nice big dude you dressed up like
an [ __ ] can I only have ten people in
your house just in suits yeah that's
gonna be awkward huh
dang yeah I wonder Joe Burrell go first
don't you think no doubt no doubt but
then it gets dicey after that cuz to a
tire boss or whatever the [ __ ] the
Alabama quarterback they think he's
gonna drop the six - the LA Chargers
which I hope happens charges dropped
their new unies today they did and they
are so we really don't
well they had those new helmets they
drop then people didn't like you happy
we're hating on the logo saying it look
like a dick
there they are they they they just
dropped this morning oh pretty filthy
where's the cheer uniforms LA was the
first woman ram brain that's a
cheerleader on their team the guy
woman LA Rams are the first ones out of
a male cheerleader left to male
cheerleaders do that have you seen I'm
Chappelle no do you think you were
cheerleader
oh wait you see these boys thank you
okay [ __ ] world champ over here what
does that that movie star wars yeah you
think you're that Jar Jar beans I don't
know I'm asking you guys yeah these are
the boys
good luck Chappelle how bad you want it
won't be in the NFL or no apple-bobbing
dance they're dancers yeah they dancers
dawg
they can't do what I do I don't think
you can do what they do look it up
whatever [ __ ] up
oh yeah you better stop meeting man if
you want to dance drug-induced nice bra
that dude is nothing either boys hit
that yeah both made the team hey you
feel a disadvantage was there was or was
there also gay man that were
cheerleading when you were cheerleading
dude [ __ ] cheerleading is like 90%
gay okay more than that though you know
99 percent you don't think 90 percent
isn't enough game to help you know I
know I feel like he's being modest there
are the only straight cheerleader I've
ever met
Wow no my arms a lot of us I got a
cousin in law dude this guy's Jamie and
he probably he trained us Topanga Canyon
he might be a damn sex offender as well
he was a male cheerleader for Alabama
named straight uh yeah he's straight but
he's okay man I'm a knight if it's if it
goit if Ozark went to a fifth season he
would be gay like it just depends but
I'll say this man my friend Cheyenne was
a cheerleader for the Chargers but do
you think that there was an unfair
advantage for gay men with Cheerilee
what do we like were they a little more
sugar than the tank
yeah they got more sugar in the tank or
were they better at it it's a good
question I mean I don't know that's a
tough question
have you seen the the Netflix
documentary chair yeah yeah I cheered at
the rival school I used to compete
against all really yeah yeah no Monica
since like 2007 you don't know much your
career is a workshop at a judo school at
a Duke coaster no like competitive cheer
like world champion they have World
Championships for just competitive your
school your whole squad was the world
champions are just you the John Henry a
[ __ ] cheerleading yeah they call me
yeah they say I was LeBron James yeah
LeBron James yeah no not LeBron I'd say
they used to say he was the Gary Payton
of Cheerilee because they use the
Latrell Sprewell cheerleader but they do
totally different than what I did like I
was like lifting in like tumbling they
did on the show cheer to them yeah you
were like more like them yes Tebow but
well that team yes they just didn't
interview on but what about here's what
I'm asking you them man y'all like y'all
not evading the question
I did well what's the dual gay men have
an advantage yes when it comes to
cheerleading because meaning more sugar
in the tank yeah like if you saw a gay
man come on do you think gay dudes that
suck okay at you at you so cute I never
seen that work there as well but um but
yeah they just yeah I mean wait what was
this question but here's the thing know
if a gay is a gay man a better chillier
than a straight man that's what I'm
asking
cuz I'm thinking of home a straight man
and I'm a cheerleader mmm where I am one
and not the other
I was pretty damn good who are you the
best that was pretty damn good the best
though could you still compete at a high
level
yeah 1% [ __ ] yeah dude and I mean last
time I competed was 2013 Brooke come on
now that's not that 107 let's go you got
both of his knees replace it and watch
my videos you'll see mine I've seen you
do back flips and [ __ ] I'm just saying I
see guys you continue to do it and they
get paid what who they're not getting
paid you just solved the boys we just
solved for that Oh taking a lot of money
for that [ __ ] team they get $50 a
game thank you right 50 more dollars in
chapelier
okay really really doing comedy
yeah that's again bringing less fighting
it's probably the same he's gonna choke
yeah dude I'll be Stan man Gundy PJ
Carlesimo oh it was what's this guy's
problem he's drinking at home he's
lonely sharing a beer with your buddy on
zoom' what's the deal
there's nobody he's at for beers now I
say hit a twelve-step man they're zoom
meetings but yeah if you can i i've
never good at it oh they had the least
have the tube no the beer bong yeah what
is that thing the beer bong is more of a
team's for yet have somebody pour the
beer and somebody holds it up you know
if two people hold your legs up with
Curtis nobody but there was no reason
for that I can also just drink like this
like the beer goes straight to your head
because it dumbest thing ever and in the
conference jumpin is drunk
yeah but we used to have the UH the
plumbing what was that thing beer bong
the beer bong a wrong and somebody put a
little oil in there something
throw some a yeah there was some extra
in there now Mike stud did a whole thing
where he had celebrities competing beer
pong challenge and he Keith created a
new little device we put at the top so
he can chug the beer faster oh wow yeah
it's nuts so you put the hole in it and
then it's like a whole device that
shoots it even faster I was never good
at chugging beer and the thumb eye thing
no yeah
well some guys I guess they just
wouldn't swallow they would literally
just hold their whole like esophagus
open and just pour beer straight in like
a pelican yeah here's got spitting up
everything your naming is just my entire
black dog college years yeah I did a lot
of what's a backpack off and actually a
welfare old cheerleading Halloween
costume on in that that's pretty cool
you know it's a bummer you have one
comma to change your profile picture I
didn't have a bond and whatever bro I
say let this guy go man hey I say do you
man
I say he didn't he probably didn't do it
let him out gang Bros young Lisa Simpson
on the saxophone oh that's a guy let's
go - lets get a female respect to do
homo closeted bizarre I would King it if
you had better taste in music hmm
cuz if you just blink saxophone that
doesn't impress me but if you can play
saxophone - really cool music then it's
great hmm like if you play saxophone -
like a
hygiene like I'm thinking more like
hip-hop songs I don't know if you do
they place sex phones and hip-hop songs
mm-hmm you can there's also ska music
and it's a very it's a like a strip mall
type of music that was popular in like
the late 90s very a real never heard of
less than J Goldfinger no too many crews
and hold on before you name any of the
other ones
no it's basically yeah it was music that
mr. music no it was like the kind of
stuff like elevator maybe during like a
file like like an elevator during 9/11
you know like it's a little more it's
like people that like it's like one of
the bands usually plays I'm like a pizza
shop late at night after their clothes
and people fight kind of and it's a lot
of people smoking cigarettes and I've
never heard of it it's lonely it's very
lonely before and after all what you
know the best saxophone thing is though
what's that song that did that if I
could work in one I know someone who has
that's a song about HIV isn't it well
the song about someone who survived HIV
what's that song about never had to
knock on wood never had to knock on wood
oh this song in person that I get
Wikipedia can you play it for me put
never had a knock on wood aids as well
[Music]
at the water pungent in Waterworld
Waterworld with Kevin Costner come on
man
and that a funnel to knock your socks on
and you weren't even at the water park
yours at home listen flag buddy horrible
[Music]
I love this song
[Music]
Oh to a dress records right but a drum
oh I didn't know that yeah so tighten up
dude all right people I'm not a coward
millions of gay men died to this song oh
look I'm not a coward she's never been
tested I like to think that if I was I
would pass look at the Brennan said he
can't read y'all hear that you're a
cheerleader shout out aids brah
and all right P aids you you can't even
get aids anymore dude
where was the lockdown when the AIDS
pandemic is going on it's like I'm
worried about that but sex like oh it's
like Oh everybody's fine man you guys
have fun out there crazy
yeah we're dropping like flies in New
York then do [ __ ] yeah speaking of AIDS
we got a relationship oh wait we never
answered the guy with the phone musician
oh the saxophone the Lisa Simpson
special I'm gonna sting the sax Russian
taxes man that's a tough gig Tech sax
bro I like it dude I think if you find a
nice streetlight or under an overpass or
something take your ass to New Orleans
go to Bourbon Street and hit that sax
and get some beads and some tits on your
face yeah yeah that's true down there
till it's definitely more regular but I
think if you're like the only guy doing
it in a certain area you could really
shine a little bit take yes the third
Street play that sax yeah take do what
the crazy thing is yesterday I saw a
musician playing somewhere and nobody's
around I'm like dude there's still a guy
dressed as an Incredible Hulk out on
Hollywood Boulevard
you know what that erases a love of the
game dude yeah that's true hey did you
go to Bourbon Street a lot grown up yeah
yeah we went a lot man yeah it was like
a place you would drive over to go over
there and get all wasted you know man
you go you go a block to the right or a
block to the left it gets all sudden
you're in first 48 yeah yeah
it's dice it gets way dice you can
easily get murdered a little bit and
then it gets also super gay you don't
know if a guy's like kind of shoot you
or [ __ ]
have sex you know pick your poison man
yeah I'm like and then it's a gun no
you're like shoot one of my ass cheeks
off well that's some good times on
Bourbon Street
oh it's dirty though yeah oh it's her
job Arthur it's the oldest bar in New
Orleans it's like that oh yeah the
absinthe house yeah yeah a place they
don't really like tricity in it they run
it just by candlelight in there it's
really good it's all candlelight it's
dark it's so dark bro it's considered
special ops
they were in their youth um that
Cheerilee that's all hacky joke
okay go say yeah they start playing the
saxophone
yeah
[Music]
what's this little thirst trap the other
guy I say King the saxophone extreme
your bro get out there and do it take
care of yourself take care of your
family brought stuff times man here we
go this is Nikki rod this guy sent
another videos didn't he
no but Nikki rod last week he was
actually an ADC C jujitsu champ familiar
yeah the guy makes the crazy videos
no that's j-rod Nikki rod was the guy
who had the pop oh no that guy's a
[ __ ] study chains with Gordon he's a
super stud yeah yeah yeah he's in a
couple videos Jai Radha the guy with the
panty on his head is a semi local second
place runner-up peeping-tom
J rosin escaped convict is on the run
now Nikki Rob hello a picture Nikki Rob
man let's give him some credit for
showing icky rods as legit as they get
he's said in a couple videos last week
one of our video one of the video there
he is with so if you view the second
picture damn that's like the best
jiu-jitsu player in the world
which one Gordon on the left
Wow now are there then boys gonna pass
the drug test
50 run boys bodied up though dude that's
like a lot of gay men who are if you're
play if you're cheering but you also are
high on ya know what could a gay man be
high on dick pops a byproduct of penis
oh come semen okay say semen bro we're
talking about science so I imagine that
if a dude shows up and he's had a half
ounce of semen or something that week
the chain I mean that's pure grade fuel
fuel bro yeah dude that is straight
rocket fuel bro that's like when sonic
dance I'll get that little magic thing
how do you cheer against that dude don't
ya that's a tough thing so that's the
only thing where I feel like they could
have some of these men or do or have an
in
P DS enhanced yeah performance-enhancing
drugs but shut out Nick your outlets
here and here he is at this is Nick
around from prison here I guess a tough
week what's up team I'm Brendan King
gang buzz buzz love you guys's [ __ ] need
some relationship advice does this girl
I'd be really into is this J was a girl
I'd be really into who got a boyfriend
and so once I found that she had a
boyfriend my dumb ass just told her that
I was gay she like man look we hit
things off the talk all the time she
thinks I'm gay and I know that there's
spark there I think the name is I'm gay
either way she just broke up with her
boyfriend and I need to know how to
slide into those dm's
help a boy out thank you love you guys
love you man get some rest
[Laughter]
like a young Jay Leno huh he looks like
a very young Jay Leno yeah you know it's
like a street Jay Leno beautiful young
man hell yeah I get for you dude bodied
up to dude you got it you gotta go the
religious route say you start going to
church you're not gay anymore you don't
like that like cheese okay that's a
great idea yeah I was gay but I'm not I
found Jesus yeah I'm not gay yeah yeah
give me a legal issue I'll never recover
from this this guy first of all lay off
the quaaludes brother you got to drop
off the ludes man boys on Pluto right
now we submit this video yeah do you
might not even be in a relationship you
might have never been in a relationship
might be playing a video game to you got
you might be playing the sim Center this
way might win on a sims K hole bro you
gotta tighten up that I've been watching
too much TV bro yeah so but I think you
got a move here okay you got an
opportunity you're friends with her you
could always say look I lied and said I
was gay because I didn't know what else
to do
you know can't
you could say I was confused I thought I
was into dudes but since I met you now
like chicks yeah you you make me like
chicks [ __ ] all these dudes and then rip
up a picture of some dudes yeah right in
front of her yeah yeah dude yeah
people's magazine because she's also
sick of dudes right now cuz she just
broke up with that guy she's upset you
can meet her there meet her halfway meet
her halfway brother what do you think
Kat this good advisor
well it's hilarious I would say go with
what the aside because it's nice yeah
what exacty say to tell her that you
lied I think girls girls love it when
guys are vulnerable Wow plus it shows
that he cared enough about how she felt
about him that he would lie about being
gay yeah you could even get a friend to
say you guys hooked up saying your name
the whole time you talk about a male
friend yeah Tigers involved it's fine
who's there yeah just say that would be
like I wasn't going down to this Tiger
gonna be a fat pine it turns out just
the Tigers I'm into chicks
but yeah man I think we've young to salt
ideas just tell her you're not gay and
since since you met her you actually
you're into chicks and she's the one
that converged you or you went to church
and because of Jesus in your heart you
don't go to hell any like chicks amen
you got two solid choices there dude
amen well that helps
yeah praise Jesus praise Jesus PJ dung
all right let's move on to a debate club
what's good Brendon was good Theo
Jeremy Willett I mean Easter Bunny here
from Reading PA and I got the Bay Club
Easter or Halloween both are candy
oriented which one's better gang gangs
buzz buzz hop hop
oriented let's go to chin what do you
think chin take it to the far east bro
and give this guy the answer that he
wants orient Easter what do you say
Easter a Halloween Easter Halloween yeah
that's a tough one I prefer Halloween
though yeah I'm sound like the toughest
decision for a chin of all time I don't
know man not at all Halloween [ __ ]
trumps the [ __ ] out of Easter Easter
[Laughter]
suckin fake zombie Jesus days you might
buy that [ __ ] no it's a shame bro here's
what I'm saying is that Easter I think
is just Halloween for people that are
afraid of [ __ ] die brah you know
afraid of [ __ ] well at least there's
Halloween but in the day innit yeah yeah
dress up like bunnies yeah Easter just
kind of a daytime Halloween it's for
it's more for children and it's more for
Jesus Christ dude it's more for Lord and
Savior yeah the Lord and Savior bro he
you know he came back you gotta
celebrate it it's more of like a family
holiday Halloween is like dark yeah
Halloween if you kill somebody you can
blame them on Halloween if you steal
something you know if you don't want to
see if you want to leave your family
also how it's way better because girls
it gives them a reason to dress up like
[ __ ] ain't no girl get her tits out on
the easter holiday man dude you go to
the right Church bro yeah because church
girls are wild man Church girls are why
yeah but they can't get them [ __ ]
sweater puppies out in the church but
they wrap them up dog and that's even
hotter right there you write little
mystery oh he says better yeah they
start sweating picture of a big cross on
her neck dude
all right you write white thighs hanging
out bra or black or black white or black
thighs hanging out or even I feel like a
laborer fun than white church it's very
upbeat
yeah somebody dies every time I buy
Church - I feel like he'll just suddenly
than us be carrying somebody doing the
lucky
Ernie's did ya bring it right back and
they're clearly acting do ya black
shirts is definitely way worth waiting
but I think it's just the same it goes
across the board for like I think black
people just in general have more they
just have more excite their just more of
like an energy that's fun yeah just more
of it just like so uptight there's not
more there's more wild energy you know
there's more of a free there's more
freelance energy more fun yeah there's
more fun energy you got a black church
do black funeral [ __ ] it's fun do you
want to die at a black frame you're like
damn this [ __ ] is hype DJ yeah this is
powerful Wingstop yes we'd stop at a
nice one yeah got a good one
yeah I do that's true brah and here's
your family right here I'm burnin that's
my stepmom yes Youngjae Schwab there
damn which one will have to write on the
right that's long neck job on the right
Wow look at that [ __ ] reach piece on
him love oh my god he probably got to
see whatever he wants my dad looks like
the ruler of Iraq that's a great Iranian
huh he does what is he white you guys
are so tan lion I'm the only tan one
dude you definitely have a little bit of
that [ __ ] debt you got a little more
beige in your bra no I feel you I'm the
darkest of my family yeah your dad very
much does a very desert e-type of yes
you know I'm trying to hear mine oh you
reminds me a little bit also of machete
Tom Sally but also of machete who is
that guy Michelle
nor Trejo yeah it's kind of offensive
because that's an ugly man but yeah all
right any Trejo dude he did small to but
we did crime he started a taco shop it
sounds like try to go ahead donut shop
no my bad
he's been 7000 movies yeah damn bro uh
he's getting that church girl cross on
to he was great and uh dusk till dawn
yeah oh I love that movie
Easter or Halloween Halloween all
goddamn day that's an easy one
Halloween's fun Easter is a bummer
it's taking a culture corner uh all
right let's see the glitz corn I think
uh Oh Halloween all day I love Halloween
me too love Halloween night right before
Christmas Halloween movies no guess up
like an [ __ ]
Halloween oh yeah yeah but Halloween you
also can like you know what he get a
drunk on Easter unless you got a [ __ ]
up yeah no yeah that's true people
aren't getting that drunk on Easter
but horror movies Halloween you can be
left out of Halloween I feel like like
if you don't plan ahead you don't get a
costume somebody doesn't invite you out
to the [ __ ]
then you just at home [ __ ] looking at
like a thing a little kind of face pain
or something you're [ __ ] lonely and
shitless you make up whatever costume
you want yeah we think I don't even know
where to go you're just wandering the
streets you know dressed up like Raggedy
Andy
what you doing sir but on Easter you
have your family it's a family day
really that's true that's true
that's a good point you'd be left out of
killing their family I just like there's
more stuff to get invited to I don't
know man it's a tough one what do you
got your shirt it sound of you should
dress happy
I don't think about holidays no holidays
well it sounds like an exciting
existence talk about sitting lowly with
face paint
I'm happy but at least I'm celebrating
it though dude oh you had a better time
than you showed up at least I'm not the
one looking at his window really man
look at that sad [ __ ] [ __ ]
saving hate comments when you could be
out there with that sad mother [ __ ]
dog it could be too sad [ __ ] if
you come out and join me bro you know
alright if you invited me maybe okay
you're right you're right so I think it
runs both ways uh I'm out all right is
that it that's it damn truth be told we
got locked out of the king and Instinct
gmail from like downloading too much
things so I just had to cobble together
the videos we had that's why maybe the
submissions were Nesterov okay okay I
don't think they were bad we got a big
archive damn it Oh locked out of it
yeah like I don't know won't let me
download anything cuz of gmail yeah
we're having we're working out this
morning I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on but we'll get back in there it
said like 24 hours I think it might just
be too much activity downloading people
just making videos in quarantine that
things poppin yeah so keep sending them
in yeah thank you guys so much we kind
of can't do the show we handle so many
oh yeah it's good present half well find
out what Jersey Knicks gonna wear next
week hey I'll bring you I'm bringing my
[ __ ] world champion ring next well
dude where your chair
yes I'm not gonna do that why why not
what let me sit he just wants to bring
the ring Brooke get that started on your
day
well the last thing I want to do is
listen to two [ __ ] men okay well I
would start listening to somebody - two
men - I'm gonna take my shirt off
hi-yah you guys need help get a [ __ ]
legit mass to do not that gay little
[ __ ] racial t-shirt she puts a full
body thick girl face mass and that's
that little thong y'all been wearing bra
not that little [ __ ] breathe strip
y'all trippin bro skooby skooby exotic
pizza I wonder if Joey I would let us
sell Joey exotic pizzas and just make
them and have him sold frozen to ship
that way extra Tigers helping of
pepperoni yeah yeah it's a good idea I
bet we could reach out to him you might
let us huh
or maybe no one's watching as a state
you can just sell Joe's I see a ton of
people making Tiger team shirts and [ __ ]
yeah and by that we mean Tom Segura like
Rogen right there
who Tom Segura who whenever you factor
in Burt you do immediately have tons of
people Brennan and Theo fighter and wait
I gotta go in and go hard in the paint I
do not think
and flow black rifle coffee I'm ready to
go I need a sponsor I am a monster about
to open up with this at my concerts flow
is contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
buggy like a fresh off keto CM red like
Andrew Santino right every Sunday is
like the great Bambino gonna take the
case oh and the case Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine
hate on me I do not mind the type of
dude got a pack of matches in his
pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
traffic couldn't beat em quit playin
like Nintendo DS you don't want the
smoke like Joey Diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows thread they
didn't I'm feeling incredible bread and
Sun him me up he said it's too loud in
the club can you pick me up a sting
and the sting bee sting cracking
and a stinking and
got it bees in the truck got the cheese
on a string as a sting King in the
stinking in the sting bee sting Rat King
and a sting king anesthesia cheese
mystery spinning and do fighter in
Creole shout out New Orleans and shout
out to Co Colorado more specifically
Boulder Brendan came in with a chip on
his shoulder but is still gold and yet
it still fire refute all I can to sting
you a liar
Brendan's got like a thousand different
hustles one of them's that Norse
director went I yours black rifle coffee
we hear you loud and clear your son on
the email like please get me out of here
it's way too loud II here watching the
Irishman eating pizzas drinking half a
beer now under Theo von looking like the
tepid do the trans Arita songs smoking
cigarettes with a snapback on that's a
hit the crib in charge snapchat it's all
good we still mess with you 18:11 Pico
Boulevard go get the head Derek and cat
y'all doing great Thursday upload not a
minute late y'all wanted to rap ahead a
demonstrate brand new studio y'all
feelin great putting Chris Delano in
this place now let's go and get your
nerd thing
King in the state
indistinct beasting Rat King
stinking and unstable beez in the trap
gotta cheese on a string dougie is a
sting King in the sting came in the
sting bee sting
as a sting a king and a stinking of bees
in the traffic of that cheese on a
strong
[Music]